we have a voicemail number that you can
call any time of day that number is 219
to david p this is a really interesting
voicemail this caller is a mental health
professional now i know some of you are
going to hear the name amanda love and
you're going to say that's the joke you
know it's the joke it's a man to love no
this is really this person's name we
made sure that this is really a mental
health professional we found that they
they are a licensed mental health
professional in their state
they are weighing in on what i said
about at what point do we see these
delusional trumpists and say not to
excuse their behavior
and not to ridicule mental illness at
what point do we say this is mental
illness
and amanda who called in and works in
this field has
very interesting insights about it take
a listen to this
hi david my name's amanda love and i'm a
mental health professional i just wanted
to follow up with you about when you're
showing the trump supporters and asking
whether they might be actually mentally
ill
and yeah some of what i saw could be
classified as delusional
which is um falls under the psychotic
realm of mental illness
some delusions are fixed and
pretty much impossible to eradicate even
with medication indeed so yeah i'm
keeping a close eye on that too because
some of it is definitely mentally ill
people that we're dealing with
in which case you know they're not being
treated or
whatever that case may be
but i appreciate everything you do and i
love all the information that you're
putting out there so thanks for what you
do and i'll keep watching thank you so
listen amanda is not i know i'll get
emails david amanda shouldn't really be
diagnosing anybody over the internet
amanda's not diagnosing anybody what
she's talking about is that generally
speaking some of the beliefs of these
trump supporters are what we would call
delusional beliefs these are these are
delusional people that falls under the
general category of psychosis and uh as
someone who
you know i've many mental health
professionals in in my family from
licensed mental health counselors
psychologists and psychiatrists
a lot of these beliefs are very
resistant to revision
uh
from
treatment with medication and even even
from psychotherapy these these can be
very stubborn and recalcitrant types of
beliefs now i think it is important to
mention
that a lot of these trump people you
know they believe uh
the q anon stuff they believe
joe biden was killed and replaced with a
body double they believe you know all of
this different stuff okay
with a lot of these people
it just so happens that their beliefs
relate to trump and many of these folks
absent trump if trump didn't exist if
trump hadn't been president and it
didn't start all of this this chain of
events that has taken place over the
last five to six years
many close to seven years now
many of these people would still have
delusional beliefs but they'd be about
something else
and this is something we've talked about
with experts on
cultish behavior conspiracism and
believers and conspiracy theories
typically these are folks who are prone
to these beliefs and it's just sort of
like what's in their environment that
they get fixated on and that's why you
see sometimes the flat earth people also
believe the jewish conspiracies
illuminati
and vaccine microchips and and on and on
and on because it's the same types of
folks who are often prone or susceptible
to these types of beliefs so very
interesting voicemail from amanda we're
not diagnosing any particular individual
here
just amanda's general assessment of the
delusional nature of some of these folks
this is not like and and i think you
know to to really underline the
difference here
there is a difference between believing
cutting taxes for the rich is good for
the economy right there's you can
massage data to make that case and
then i can say no but the data is
inaccurate
if you believe joe biden was killed and
replaced with a body double in order to
steal the election from trump
that is different there is a major
difference between oh i disagree with
you on tax policy and you think biden's
an imposter because the real biden was
killed those are not equivalent in any
way and there's a difference between a
political disagreement
and some of these delusional beliefs
speaking of delusional beliefs on the
bonus show today it looks like florida
governor ron desantis is signaling that
he would support a so-called don't say
gay bill it's been years since we've
talked about these don't say gay bills
and they're they're vile and we're going
to talk about it also a record 31
million americans will be betting on the
super bowl am i one of them
um
most of you probably know the answer but
i'll answer it on the bonus show and
also there is an 85 mile wide comment
heading in our direction from the oort
cloud not going to hit earth not gonna
i'm not gonna you know i know that there
are some people who for the bonus show
they would do really dishonest things oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad right i'm not
going to do that i'm not going to
pretend maybe this comment is going to
hit us it's not but it's an interesting
story nonetheless so all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up now
at joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code wow 22 for a
discount and i will see you then